all right we are live now at noon
central for another installation of the
live reading
from my book uh here it is reason
fulfilled by revelation the 1930s
christian philosophy debates in france
that came out in 2011
from catholic university of america
press the work of about eight years on
my part to
bring this volume to fruition
while we're waiting for people to show
up i'm going to say just a little bit
about the uh the project the book
um
people who may be tuning in for the
first time could probably use a little
bit of a refresher so this is a book
that consists primarily of translations
from what it says the 1930s christian
philosophy debates in france and these
were indeed debates largely among
christian thinkers in france and a few
other francophone
countries about the
historical existence the possibility the
nature
of something that could be called
christian philosophy
and for a lot of people this is kind of
a no-brainer you know well obviously
there's christian philosophy right what
about saint thomas aquinas or people
like that and there was a lot of debate
at the time about whether we should
consider
people like aquinas or augustine or
contemporary christian authors as
philosophical and what's really cool
about this debate
is it's something that we can call meta
philosophical
it reveals to us a lot of the
assumptions that people make about the
nature of not just christian philosophy
but philosophy
itself and its relations with things
that are not philosophy like theology or
religious practices and faith or
the historical uh you know religion that
we call christianity which is itself an
incredibly complicated thing right so
it's doing the research for this was
really cool
now at this point in the readings from
it we're past the long historical
introduction that i did about 100 pages
long
and we read emil brejie's um
is there a christian philosophy which he
answers no there's not a christian
philosophy and now we're going to look
at uh the side for it the very first
proponent of it etienne
philosopher somebody who also did a lot
of work on other medieval
thinkers like augustine bonaventure
bernard of clairvaux
wrote a piece on anselm that that i've
used myself where he calls anselm's work
not christian philosophy but christian
gnosis i like clement of alexandria
and jill
was enlisted to be
sort of the champion of christian
philosophy at this society frances di
philosophy
meeting in 1931 that is really the
kickoff of the debates proper
and um i could only publish the
translations of his presentation he also
engaged with
some of the rationalist thinkers
including emile bravier and his old
teacher leon brunchfig in some really
interesting dialogue and dialectic but
that they you know the society francis
di philosophy said no you can't
translate that stuff or can't publish
the translation of that
so what we have here is just his part of
the presentation
it runs for about 12 pages or so so i'm
going to start reading and then after
this
i'll stick around for any questions
comments people have about the book the
topics the thinker this is not a general
ama
so
you know i'll
defer those sort of questions to an
actual ama but if you've got questions
about what we're talking about here
i'm happy to answer them so
no further ado let's start
either
the notion of christian philosophy
accounts of meetings society frances de
philosophy 21 march 1931.
mr etienne gilson presents to the
society the following considerations
the expression christian philosophy is
used frequently enough in our time but
it is not clear whether it corresponds
to a distinct notion
we propose to rigorously examine whether
this notion exists and if it exists to
define it is such a notion possible
one one first point of view can be
defined from which it appears impossible
it is that of certain medieval
theologians for whom philosophy because
it is a purely rational discipline is by
definition a source of error there
cannot be a christian philosophy then
because revelation dispenses with
philosophy just as truth dispenses with
error
two
a second point of view equally opposed
to the first leads to the same negation
it is that of pure rationalism if
philosophy is the work of reason and of
reason alone it cannot accommodate
itself to any subordination to dogma
or a religious faith in whatever sense
this may take
in these conditions the notion of
christian philosophy cannot have any
intrinsic relation to the notion of
christianity there can be christians who
would be philosophers but no christian
philosophers there cannot be a christian
philosophy because philosophy dispenses
with revelation just as
reason dispenses with prejudice
three
pure rationalism is ordinarily
accompanied by a global condemnation of
medieval philosophy whose subordination
to religious dogma
disqualifies it insofar as philosophy
in order to cleanse medieval philosophy
of this reproach certain neotomists
accept the rationalist position on the
problem but contest the validity of the
conclusion drawn from it
for them philosophy owes nothing except
to reason it is only due to its
rationality that tomism should be a
philosophy and a true philosophy
according to these recent interpreters
of st thomas the result is that if the
thomas philosophy is philosophy
it is in so far as rational not insofar
as christian these neotomists agree in
their turn that the expression christian
philosophy does not have any meaning the
notion to which it would correspond is
impossible
four
the augustinian tradition
in general rises up against this
conclusion
those of its representatives who speak
of christian philosophy use this
expression in many different though
related senses a
in saint augustine's work it designates
the philosophy of christians by
opposition to the differing philosophies
of the pagans
be in many augustinians works it
designates saint augustine's philosophy
or that which they attribute to him by
opposition to the philosophy of saint
thomas
which to them seems to have sacrificed
certain of christianity's fundamental
theses to aristotle's pagan
philosophy see
going beyond the purely historical plane
to strive for the philosophical plane
certain others see this expressions
justification in the augustinian
perspective because augustinian
philosophy comprehends man in its
concrete state that is by including in
it his religious life philosophy that
faithfully translates the christian
man's experience is necessarily
christian five
such a conception runs into difficulties
not only because in the concrete it
identifies with each other orders that
can unite there without being confused
but especially
because it refuses to analyze the
concrete into concepts that is to give
it the only conceivable
philosophical translation
it is necessary to return to the formal
distinction of the philosophical order
and the religious order but can we do
this while retaining a meaning for the
notion of christian philosophy
six
i don't have let's do six like that we
can under the condition of bringing the
problem back to the historical plane
it is a matter of knowing whether
christianity has played an observable
role
in the constitution of certain
philosophies
if philosophical systems exist purely
rational in their principles
and in their methods whose existence
would not be explained without the
existence of the christian religion the
philosophies they define
merit the name of christian philosophies
this notion does not correspond to a
conception of a pure essence that of the
philosopher or that of the christian
but to the possibility of a complex
historical reality that of a revelation
generative of reason the two orders
remain distinct
even if the relation that unites them be
intrinsic
seven
this interpretation of the notion of
christian philosophy does not indicate
anything more than the possibility of
such a notion it leaves open the double
question of the existence of a
corresponding historical reality
affirmed by certain historians but
denied by others and of the dogmatic
value of the results obtained by such a
philosophy if it exists this last
problem depends solely on purely
rational critique the only one by which
christian philosophy could be judged
but by which it could be entirely judged
since it presents itself as philosophy
so that that's his precede of what he's
going to say next
the expression christian philosophy is
one of those that emerged spontaneously
from a historian's pen when he discusses
the movement of philosophical ideas that
developed between the second and the
14th centuries of the christian era
there are even entire works that are
explicitly devoted to retracing this
history for example that of heinrich
ritter or that of albert stukel outside
of these specialized works the
expression is frequently encountered in
the works of a number of historians and
philosophers but either it is used
without any provisional determination of
its content or when they make the attack
the effort to define it the definitions
they give are more or less divergent
there can be then some interest in
discussing its meaning and the first
question that gets asked
is that of knowing whether the notion is
not contradictory
this is why before everything else i
would like to discuss such a notions con
conditions of possibility
there is a first point of view from
which the notion of christian philosophy
is impossible that of pure theologism
such as we find it in certain doctrines
of the middle ages they are much more
rare than one thinks but there were some
for them the christian religion excludes
philosophy
because
christianity is a doctrine of salvation
because one can be saved without
philosophy and even because it is more
difficult to be saved with philosophy
than without it
saint peter damien is a typical example
of this state of mind he mistrusts not
only philosophy but also even grammar
addressing himself to monks broaching
the question from the perspective the
total renunciation of the age
he advises them to first renounce
rational knowledge for it was by
promising our first parents the science
of good and evil that the devil
introduced evil into the world
cupiditatum skientiae quasi ducum
excertesis exertitus posuit medieval
philosophy was the negation
of this obscurantism but it still it did
exist
for men of that type the very notion of
christian philosophy could only rest on
an equivocation it signifies that where
christianity is it is useless or
dangerous that philosophy be
at the opposite extreme
there are those for whom where
philosophy is it is dangerous that
christianity should be this is the
position of pure rationalism
that is of those who do not accept that
rationalism should have a limited role
whatever the content may be of the
diverse philosophies reason elaborates
it is insofar as rational that they are
philosophies to wish to subordinate them
to a dogma or to a faith is to destroy
philosophy's essence
so what would a christian philosophy be
uh philosophia an killer teelogia
but theology bases itself on faith which
is something irrational
to make philosophy the servant of
theology is therefore to make the
rational depend on the irrational that
is to suppress its very rationality
if then someone would be satisfied with
wishing to prepare or to justify the
acceptance of faith by reason he would
substitute apologetics for philosophy in
either case the term philosophy cannot
be applied to the exercise of a reason
whose principles and end are not
rational this is why from this point of
view the notion of christian philosophy
is contradictory and impossible there
can be christians who are philosophers
but no christian philosophers
even more since the temptation of
allowing their philosophical conclusions
to be suggested by their faith will be
for them constant inevitable
one can say that in a sense they will be
philosophers only in spite of their very
christianity such men will succeed in
their enterprise only
under the condition of carefully setting
aside their christianity at the door to
their study
this is what the men of the middle ages
did not do and their failure to
establish a genuine philosophy is only
the exterior sign of the intrinsic
impossibility of a christian philosophy
it is as tactless to speak of a
christian philosophy as it is of a
christian science said foyerbach
the notion of christian philosophy is
absurd
it goes without saying that no
neo-scholastic philosopher agrees with
this global condemnation of medieval
speculation and none of them will agree
that their faith would be an impediment
for reason to the contrary all of them
agree with saint thomas that truth
cannot contradict truth and that
consequently what faith finds agrees
substantially with what reason proves
they would go even further for it faith
agrees with reason if not in its method
at least in its content all factual
disagreement between the two is an
indication of an error in the
philosophical order and a warning that
one has to re-examine the problem
still
all the neo-scholastic philosophers add
that in so far as philosophy philosophy
is the exclusive work of reason rational
in its principles it is also rational in
its method and its conclusions never
does dogma play a role of a principle of
deduction never is it invoked as a proof
these two orders are coordinated perhaps
they are even in a certain sense
subordinated but on different planes
philosophy taken in itself is judged
only by reason we can ask in a case like
this what becomes of the notion of
christian philosophy
for certain philosophers of this school
it is very simple it disappears
for these neoscholastic philosophers
there can no more be a christian
philosophy than there can for a pure
rationalist because within the
philosophical order grasped with
precision and insofar as philosophical
their rationalism is a pure one their
opponents can contest whether the
neo-scholastics are placed in the
conditions required for reasons use and
they can argue that this is the cause of
their lack of success but they must
recognize that the notion of philosophy
is the same in both cases in return
ascending to this notion of philosophy
these neo-scholastics believe that they
have to agree that the notion of
christian philosophy is contradictory
this is what ccr says explicitly in the
preface of la fello sophie scholastic
expose defending
the reverend pere
at bottom there is no christian
philosophy but only a true philosophy
that agrees fully with a christian
religion from which it is perfectly
distinct
one could cite other identical or
analogous declarations but they would
not add anything to syrups whose clarity
leaves nothing to be desired
so by two inverse methods we arrive at
the same conclusions according to pure
theologism christian philosophy
signifies christianity without
philosophy and the unity of both terms
is produced by confusing philosophy with
religion according to foyerbach the
contrary is true for their unity is
produced by confusing religion with
philosophy as representation and concept
their content is substantially identical
according to sierra neo-scholastics of
the same tendency the two orders are
distinct and sub-alternated but
separated as they are by the real
distinction of essences that they
express
their notions are and must remain
separated in any case the result is the
same for whether one in some sense
limits the two concepts of christianity
and philosophy
or whether one separates them the
conclusion is the
impossibility of uniting them in the
same notion
the augustinian tradition
raises its centuries old protest against
this conclusion as do those who use the
expression christian philosophy as if it
offered an intelligible meaning to
thought
the problem is that they do not often
define its meaning and because of this
we find ourselves in a predicament today
clearly a first meaning vague and
inconstant must be eliminated at the
start
many historians designate by this
expression the philosophies worked out
by christians and particularly by those
christians who proclaim their intention
to think in agreement with
christianity's teachings really though
that articulates the question only
implicitly
four if one admits that philosophy has
bound itself in intrinsic relations with
christianity it remains to be shown
precisely that such relations are
conceivable the global feeling of a
difference of aspect in philosophy
before and during christianity can be
grounded historically
but it does not tell us anything about
the possible intelligibility of a
relation of philosophy to christianity
we must leave behind the plane of
empiricism to reach the one of
explanation
the expression itself as far as i know
derives from saint augustine and to my
knowledge at least was only used by him
one time
in his work it signifies the only true
philosophy una vera philo sofia the
authentic philosophy german philosophy
in another text without using this
expression he declares it as the
inspired authors of sacred scripture who
are the true philosophers
thus he certainly means to say that if
the christian philosophy is the only
true one it is precisely insofar as
christian and particularly because it is
inspired by the bible and the gospels
on the other hand although we know
augustine does not in any way confuse
the order of faith and the order of
reason
it must still be admitted that from his
point of view a relation as possible
between the two distinct orders
of knowledge all we can say about this
without entering into details of text
whose analysis is difficult is that for
augustine as for every other philosopher
philosophy is the love of wisdom but for
saying augustine and so far as christian
it is the christian god who is wisdom
since the christian is only the only one
to know where wisdom is he is the only
one who loves it and consequently he is
the only true philosopher on the other
hand where does the christian find his
god in scripture
and how does he cleave to it by faith in
scripture what distinguishes the
christian philosopher from the pagan
philosopher is therefore that he is
placed by faith in possession of a truth
that is believed which reason has only
to transform into a truth that is known
this is the meaning of the famous credo
uttan telegam the two orders remain
distinct for knowledge as knowing is not
having not believing but while retaining
its essence completely in the conditions
of its exercise reason enters into
intimate relation with faith for thanks
to faith that can rediscover what it
would never have succeeded in
discovering
a philosophy that openly establishes
itself on this plan cannot fail to
provide evidence of the constancy and
the depth of its agreement with the
content of faith and by a natural
consequence it must appear to history's
eyes to be identical with christian
philosophy itself not only in its spirit
but in its content this is why
in the 13th century when tomism
established itself on different
philosophical bases the augustinians
accused it not only of breaking with
saint augustine
but also thereby breaking with the
christian tradition in order to return
to aristotle's pagan philosophy
in this sense
christian philosophy would signify the
philosophy attributed by certain
medieval thinkers to saint augustine and
opposed to the thomas philosophy this is
the meaning that the expression still
had in the 17th century and andre
martinez philosophy philosophy of
christiana whose traces one finds in the
preface to mal brashes search after
truth a meaning that fab kept in the
preface to his 19th century re-edition
of martin's book and which would
doubtless still find offenders in our
own time in order to discuss it we would
have to examine the whole problem of
tomism's significance needless to say i
do not dream of doing that here all the
more because if i had to remind you of
this meaning of the expression i'm
analyzing because it is a historical
reality
it still remains only a historical
reality
supposing the meaning were justified
and i'm persuaded to the contrary the
result would be that tomism was not a
christian philosophy which would satisfy
feuerbach without troubling syrup but
not because christian philosophy is
impossible since since saint augustine
would remain to represent it
so the only thing remaining for us to do
is to see whether the relation some
suppose real
is possible how would we be able to
conceive of this
both saint thomas's philosophy and saint
augustine's philosophy are philosophies
of the concrete but their attitude
towards the concrete is not the same
saint augustine always seeks notions
comprehensive enough to embrace the
concrete in its complexity st thomas
always seeks notions precise enough to
define the elements that constitute the
concrete
in a word the former expresses the
concrete the latter analyzes it this is
why to the mind of an augustinian the
notion of christian philosophy offers no
particular difficulty he knows that
faith is faith and reason is reason but
he adds that a man's faith and a man's
reason are not too uncoordinated
accidents of the same substance
in his view the real is the man himself
a profound unity not dissociable into
juxtaposed elements as fragments of a
mosaic would be
a unity in which nature and grace reason
and faith cannot each one function on
its own like in a mechanism whose pieces
would have been purchased at the store
as separate parts
if therefore a christian man
philosophizes and if he expresses
himself truly in his philosophy this
cannot fail to be a christian philosophy
and this will be
from end to end both christian and
philosophical without it being
analyzable into elements each of which
would be equivalent to a negation of the
whole
such a conception is quite seductive it
even contains a deep truth whose
opponents have sometimes aired by
considerably by allowing it to be lost
preserving which is perhaps the
augustinian conception's proper function
this truth
is the real unity
of the elements of the concrete in the
subject where they are realized
whatever doctrine one identifies with
considering a being's unity to be made
from the combination of other beings is
a deadly blow to philosophy and what is
true of being is true of thought if
there were a faith and a reason in us
whose being was radically distinct from
that of a thinking substance to which
they belong
we could not say of any of us that he
was a
man
in this sense
everyone agrees that faith and reason
are rooted in the unity of the concrete
subject because they have forgotten this
certain neotomis even though tomism does
not oblige them to do this
have believed that they had to deny
christian philosophy's possibility
because it has been keenly sensible of
this
augustinian augustinianism has always
maintained the intelligibility of this
expression
let us go on further if this is true it
must necessarily be the case that
christian philosophy would be christian
in so far as its philosophy if it were
otherwise the notion would not only lack
its proper content it would be in
contradiction with the fundamental unity
of the concrete subject that it
expresses the result is that every
christian philosophy
will be traversed impregnated nourished
by christianity as by a blood that
circulates it or rather a life that
animates it one will never be able to
say that here the philosophical ends and
the christian begins it will be
integrally christian and integrally
philosophical or it will not be
these are not secondary concessions made
to the augustinian position on the
problem but the open recognition of the
fact that this position is the true
position on the problem and the reality
that it defines is really the reality to
be explained all that remains
is asking whether the correct
description of the reality to be
explained is equivalent to its
explanation
for therein lies the whole the entire
problem
in this examination i abstract from
another problem the that of the relation
of the different elements integrated in
the unity the concrete subject and of
the way in which they're integrated
what remains for us to ask is whether
the task of philosophy consisted noting
this unity or analyzing it into concepts
it is impossible to follow the
bergsonian critique of the concept or mr
maurice blondel's critique of notional
knowledge without sensing they
correspond to a permanent philosophical
need they are and remain necessary
against those who
taking concepts for things
conclude that things are made exactly as
the pieces of the things whose concepts
we have
but condemnation of philosophies of the
concept is not a
necessary deduction from that what is
true is that no philosophy the concept
will be able to make the concrete it
analyzes not be a concrete and that no
philosophy of the concrete will be able
to make our only manner of thinking this
concrete unity not consist in expressing
it in a multiplicity of concepts
conceptualism expresses precisely
indistinct concepts the elements that
the judgment relates to the unity of the
concrete to remain drawn short drawn up
short of the concept is to remain drawn
up short of philosophy at one time or
another we all require somebody lead us
back there for concepts are born
from the concrete unity of the real
but if it is necessary for us to return
there it is equally necessary we do not
remain there
they
invite thought to bathe in the reel and
certainly nothing is more refreshing
than a bath but one does not live in a
bathtub
where philosophers of this type lead one
astray
is not in their entering into the
concrete but they're refusing to exit
from it every critique of the concept
that concludes by its suppression
thereby concludes in the suppression of
philosophy whereas wisdom would consist
rather and ceaselessly returning to the
real in order to more and more
adequately express it in concepts that
is what we can at least try to do
the concrete unity of the christian
philosopher is not at issue and there is
no danger that we will destroy it since
it does not depend on us the formal
distinction of christianities and
philosophies concepts cannot be made the
focus of this discussion for they
correspond to essences over whose
content our reason has no power it can
only conceive them and take note of them
if it was a matter of making philosophy
and religion be held together in a
single
concept
or to the contrary of reconstructing a
christian philosophy with two concepts
the undertaking would be impossible but
precisely because philosophy and
religion are concepts
they do not exist
there exist only religious men
and philosophers
and just as the unity of these subjects
does not prohibit us from analyzing them
into distinct concepts the distinction
of these concepts does not
prohibit us from reconnecting them to
the unity of their subjects only in a
case like this
we cannot claim to express the real by a
single concept we need at least two
contained in a single notion that they
integrate
in no case will be will we be able to
make a christian's philosophy not be
purely rational lacking which it would
no longer be philosophy
but once this philosopher is also a
christian
his reasons exercise will be that of a
christian's reason that is not a reason
of a different type than that of
non-christian philosophers but a reason
that laborers under
different conditions
and i do not believe that it would be a
very strong objection to say that in
this case the christian is a philosopher
who puts himself in the worst conditions
in which to philosophize for it is true
that his reason is that of a subject in
which there is something non-rational
his religious faith
but
i await
someone who will show me a true
philosopher a pure philosopher the
concrete realization of a unique concept
in which reason would not cohabit with
any irrational of this sort and i ask
especially whether the philosophical
life is not precisely a constant effort
to bring what is irrational in us to the
state of rationality
what is difficult for us is
distinguishing between the irrational
and the not yet rational
and once one's choice is made there's
still an issue of knowing the time when
the possibilities of the rationality of
the non-rational one is chosen are
exhausted
what is peculiar to the christian is
being convinced of the rational
fertility of his faith and being sure
that this fertility is inexhaustible if
we pay attention that is the true
meaning of saint augustine's credo orton
telegram and saint anselm's fide
squadrons intellectum a christian's
effort to draw some of reasons knowledge
from faith and revelation
that is why these two formulas are the
true definition of christian philosophy
if we want to grant this notion it's
proper meaning it is important to keep
it on the plane of concrete reality and
partic particularly that of history
if there have been philosophies that is
systems of rational truths whose
existence cannot be explained
historically without taking account of
christianity's existence these
philosophies should bear the name of
christian philosophies they are
philosophy since they are rational and
they are christian
since the rationality they have
contributed would not have been
conceived without christianity
for the relation for both concepts to be
intrinsic it is not enough that a
philosophy be compatible with
christianity it is necessary
christianity have played an active role
in the very establishment of that
philosophy there are in fact elements
compatible with christianity and plato's
work and aristotle's work and there's no
trace of christian philosophy in their
work but without christianity one would
have a difficult time explaining what
saint augustine or st thomas added to
their work if we hold back
from the historical problem of the
existence and content of christian
philosophy we can try to determine in
some way a priori the features they
would have to have by virtue of this
notion
one
these will be philosophies that consider
the judeo-christian revelation as a
morally necessary aid to reason thanks
to that guide they can eliminate errors
add new truths to the old ones complete
the old truths or simply preserve them
two insofar as christian they will limit
themselves to philosophical problems
about which revelation can serve them as
a guide god man with his relations to
god nature and its relations to god this
is saint augustine's novaremte novarame
whose tradition bosuet continues in his
treatise de la connaissance today
they are therefore insofar as christian
philosophies with a clearly vast but
limited program
three it is impossible to determine a
priori what additional types of
knowledge different christian
philosophers will consider to be
required for the knowledge of god and
oneself but as far reaching as these
additional types of knowledge may be
they will be introduced into a christian
system only on account of their end thus
these will be unified philosophies
because centered on the idea of the
christian god
that said we ought perhaps to add
christian philosophy does not exclude
philosophy pure and simple of which it
is a species
although it manifests a marked
prediction for the problem and treats it
does not prohibit the others for the
philosopher for the christian
philosopher it is simply not its proper
function to occupy itself with the other
problems
that is why if there are christian
philosophies we can predict their
fertility will be manifested in the
fields of metaphysics
anthropology and morals
more than in any others it remains for
us to ascertain whether there have been
such philosophies that is a problem that
is a matter for the history of
philosophy alone and one about which the
historians are not in agreement this
problem resolved another one would still
remain that of the value of these
philosophies this problem is a matter
for pure rational critique working on
history's data
that is the only critique that can judge
this philosophy but this philosophy is
entirely judicable by it since it
presents itself as a philosophy
so that is a t angel song's contribution
which i translated from
his society frances di philosophy
presentation at the 1931 meeting uh you
can find it in here and reason fulfilled
by revelation which
we're getting that idea in part from
jill so right
i think he could probably recognize that
in the way that he has formulated what
christian philosophy would be and how it
would be
produced
so
at this point in time
about a little past 12 30 i'll take any
questions or comments about the book the
authors involved the topics
that you want to bring up and hang out
here for for a little while
while people are doing that
i'll just you know for anybody who tuned
in late i will say
we're about well we're not halfway
through the book at this point we've
been doing these readings now for a
couple months
on thursdays getting a couple of them in
each each month and so we went through
the entire introduction which is almost
100 pages
of the book and it's you know that's
important stuff to set the stage but the
real highlight of the book are the
actual translations there you can see
jill someone's right there
um we did breer's next uh next session
we're going to be doing maurice
blondel's first contribution to the
debate does christian philosophy exist
as philosophy in which he's going after
jill so among other people
and then we're going to see him going
after brahier and is there a christian
philosophy published in the review de
metaphysique a morale those are all
things from the 1931
period of the debate there were other
things that were published but i i
couldn't put them into the
the book in part because as i remarked
at the start the society france says the
philosophy would only allow um
a portion of the
the session to be translated namely the
presentation by jill sohn it wouldn't
allow the
the back and forth between jill so and
the other people involved to be to be
translated which is really unfortunate i
also didn't translate um
mara ten's contribution because it found
its way into a later document the um
his book on christian philosophy i'm
blanking on it right now i want to say
it's the problem of christian philosophy
which was um
quickly translated into english and so
it it we don't really need to do that
there were also a few minor um
participants in that debate like edward
law for example
blondel wrote a letter blondel by that
time was near blind and so it wasn't
easy for him to travel
or participate so he wrote a letter
instead
and there were um uh there was another
article i think uh i want to say surio's
article
might have been published in in 32 i've
actually got this like lengthy
bibliography that takes about 20 pages
in the back of the book
yeah so here's here's the stuff that was
actually published that year
um
oh yeah marcel de court so the notion
philosophy
really interesting but i didn't have
enough space
for it in here
reggie jolie vet published two books
uh essay sir la rapport antonio
craic
i don't think either of them have been
translated
um cramer a german uh guy wrote saint
augustine philosophy philosopheratienne
reading the the
publications for the 100 year
anniversary and then there was a there
was an entry by this guy uh hermann
zeltner he was in german zircato lesion
culture philosophy
all right let me take some of these
questions or comments mark says i like
that idea of reason laboring under
different conditions
it's a nice contrast to the notion of a
singular neutral rationality yeah i mean
this this idea that people have that you
know like in the
mid to late 20th century we discovered
that rationality is not this
enlightenment thing that's exactly the
same in every person
these people involved in the christian
philosophy debates like like atheist and
uh jacques mariten
gabriel marcel maurice blondel they were
cognizant of that already by then as a
matter of fact atien born
his entire piece really centers around
that that issue
um our rationality always coexists with
things that are not rationality to put
it in terms of
later 20th century continental
philosophy we always have the other
inside us
right
eastern anime i hope hopped in midway so
i'm not really caught up on it but i
have a question of concerning this reel
that was mentioned by the authors that
the same concept of lacan's idea has no
connection to lacan's idea right he just
means reality the the what we experience
as opposed to abstraction that people
make of of reality
um
lacan's reel actually by the way means
several different things it's not it's
not a fixed concept um and it takes on
additional weight later on in his work
than it does before
mark says joe so mentioned metaphysics
morals and a third thing anthropology
now this is important when he says
anthropology
he does not mean
cultural anthropology or
um archaeology or
these other things right you know
measuring bones and digging up sites
that could be that could be
feeding into it but what what he
actually means is the study of human
nature there's some anthropology
as a discipline like so many others came
out of philosophy anthropos man right
anthropology the study of human beings
as such it comes later to me in the
study of cultures and you know our
evolution and things like that but
originally it means study of human
nature so
plato and aristotle are already involved
in anthropology
you see this reflected in what's left of
catholic education at the university
level in the united states and i say
what's left of it because
those who actually know what what the
you know
philosophy departments and the core
curriculum is like in many uh nominally
catholic universities like marquette
university down the road know that there
used to be in place of an intro to
philosophy class it was typically
philosophy of human nature
right not not just a sort of smattering
smorgasbord of topics but a more focused
thing and then that would lead into an
ethics class and then that would lead
into other philosophical studies
there's a tendency
and i've seen this in many catholic
institutions to
reduce the core reduce the general
studies curriculum
from requiring three philosophy classes
down to two and from two down to one
and trying to make that one do
everything and basically just giving
their students a intro to philosophy
class rather than a philosophy of human
nature class so
now mark is bringing up another thing
that i was actually thinking about as we
were going reading through this
do you think aesthetics should be added
to the list
yes i do
and it's interesting that jill song
doesn't identify that
um
i think jacques marata
who is willing to go so far as to argue
that perhaps beauty
should be another transcendental you
know beyond just the transcendentals
like being good unity that he says
beauty should should be one
and i think we can go further in terms
of aesthetics and talk not just about
beauty or the sublime but about all
sorts of other aesthetic values as well
and there's and there's interconnections
between
uh
moral philosophy and aesthetics
you know when we talk about the beauty
of a character right
um
that is a problem that straddles both
domains the entire domain of what in
greek
was called the carlos which we translate
is beautiful fine noble
honorable it's a form of goodness and
it's usually the object of aesthetics
more than other fields and so yeah i
think i think mark is on point about
that
aesthetics
aesthetics would be where we'd expect to
see some stuff it's interesting too
because
if any of your fans of umberto echo
the great semiotician
he actually has a book
which i believe might have been his
dissertation
on the aesthetics of saint thomas
aquinas
very very interesting work you know
and i think that would be a good example
of somebody identifying things that are
coming about
the wager someone's describing it
because of the coexistence of faith and
and reason in
this this guy thomas aquinas
mark says my colleague's argument would
be that christianity saved the human
body from greek pessimism resurrection
of the flesh vindicates the body of
something beautiful and worth studying
um i am maybe i mean i i'm i'm pretty
hesitant about generalizing
uh
about you know the christian view and
the greek view because the greek view as
it turns out was quite diverse
you know um which greek view are we
talking about that of neo-platonus that
is stoics that of
people who are
embracing a hedonism that goes way
beyond that of the epicureans and say
live you know
have a good time because we're going to
die tomorrow
um
it's not as if there's a greek view and
and when we look at early christian
work the same thing also goes for um
uh jewish thought
you know we we find a lot of um
on the one hand we find a lot of
diversity right so things aren't as as
simple as just like the jewish idea or
the greek idea
and on the other hand we find a lot of
interaction and confluence um between
the the two of them you know so like
think about filo of alexandria
who is
a jewish author living in really the
cultural capital at that time of judaism
um i mean you could say a lot more was
going on in alexandria with jews in
exile than was happening in in palestine
itself or in babylon or or in other
places where the diaspora had gone to
um
and he brings together jewish scriptures
along with um elements from stoicism and
neoplatonism together into a kind of
fusion of his own
and he's pretty pessimistic about the
body as well
it really depends on on which which
christian we're looking at i mean we
know that christianity can become pretty
body negative in in some of its uh
manifestations
so it's not as if there's anything like
intrinsic to the christian point of view
that will will
you know pull us out of greek pessimism
i'm not even sure that there really is a
greek pessimism as as such
that we could we could um
highlight
those are some good questions um
joe song is i'm going to say this too
reading him
it's always a fun thing
rereading this stuff that i translated
from these great authors because with
very few exceptions
um
they're they're great writers too there
are a few in here who like there's
there's a guy devil vey
who's involved in the discussion with
blondel who's right he's just a terrible
writer
but the rest of them i mean
brejierre he's he's a he's a good
stylist blondel is a little bit more
turgid
in his prose um certian is kind of a
delight
to read we're going to get to him after
a while
we've got
blown dowel and marcel and bourne coming
up
in the in the coming months so
yeah
all right any other questions or
comments or stuff like that otherwise
i'm going to get myself some lunch
before i have to start doing some
filming
having to do with somebody who has zero
connection to these debates
about stanislaw lem
for
the thing
coming up this weekend
so eastern anime on a scale of one to
ten how bad of a writer is hegel or have
i been misled i don't know i mean read
them
um in in his german he's i mean he's
like uh he's he's a four i guess
um he's um
he's just not a great writer um he's a
great thinker
and it's well worth studying his stuff
but
he is not particularly clear in his
expression and some books are better
than others you know often his lectures
are quite clear
but
we don't read nobody reads hegel for the
the beautiful beauty of the pros whereas
you can say like with nature
schopenhauer maybe we do
mark what are you going to have for
lunch leftovers um and then see what
else i can scarf up i got to get i got
to get shooting this
this stuff so yeah
all right any other questions comments
i believe we are on for next thursday
let me check the calendar real quick
for doing another
one of these
yep we're doing blondel next week so
uh if you if you enjoyed this you might
you might find that one fun as well and
uh
again reading from uh re
uh reason fulfilled by revelation i
almost used eighty angel songs uh uh
revelation generative of reason because
i got him on the brain so we're doing it
we're going through this book bit by bit
and um
well here's here's the last question
zacamo if not out of topic could you
tell me what christianity brought to
philosophy myriad things a different
concept of the person
a different understanding of morality
and key elements within it
as mark was mentioning aesthetics
the
not just christianity but also judaism
consid considerations of being as
created ex nihilo just all sorts of
things right
ricky i'm wondering what nature would
say about christian philosophy i don't
know read nietzsche
it won't take you long to figure out
what he's saying about about
christianity right
and about christian thinkers so um that
that's one of those things where you
want to actually read the read the guy
um all right so i'm gonna end it here
glad to see all of you thanks for coming
along for another literary ride and i'll
see you next week